hast du jemals an einem öffentlichen ort
der schule der uni oder sonst wo es
nicht ein zu hause oder unterwegs
masturbiert ja ja ja das ist zu einem
neuen video sollte die haben wir treten
heute an leute team rotes herz gegen
tiflis herz in der liebenzeller manche
von euch haben vielleicht schon einen
detektor video hoffmann kanal gesehen
konnten tagen das dann wieder
verschwunden ist liegt daran dass tanzen
bundes geklaut hat die schaltung von dir
ist wirklich weil die angebote der wald
das bietet eine woche das video geklaut
folgen die ganze fest dass sie darauf
war bisher einfach sagen wir geben euch
hier werden sie heute folgendermaßen
machen das ist ein lügendetektor vorne
zeigt der an wie stratege ist von
wahrheit eine led bis zu maximal gelogen
fünf led ist man kann hier hinten die
stärke von den strom shop einstellen die
man bekommt wenn man betreue jetzt sind
eindruck bekommt was dieses ding seriöse
werte oder wirklich sehr jung ist es
vermittelt leute dieses ding ist der
achtgrößte kaputt also richtig kraftvoll
ich habe nirgends belegt
das ist ein extrem seriöse leute selbst
besteht nicht es stimmt wir fahren alle
vereint dann kommen stufe 2 3 und dann
am ende kommt stufe 50 slider verdanken
am ende der extremen sprung schaffen
dass gegenseitig fragen und wir legen
los du fängst an vier tagen sogar bis zu
antworten drückst du auf analysieren
dann läuft
zeit beantworten und dann kriegst du
schon gefragt haben als erste frage hast
du deine schulzeit mal ein lehrer
beleidigt
die münze nahmen beide nase gehabt warum
liebst du denn dass du bist ein bisschen
wert beimisst rüberkommen also lasst
euch mal direkt würden das heißt ich
packe eine unterschiedliche hochwertig
mal hast du damals sind einer stolzen
schon einen ständer wegen erpressung
bekommen
also was wir nicht haben erzählt ja
gleich gegner in der gruppe 2 als genau
im auge
ich mache ich mir ja genauso schön nicht
unter die haut geht so fasst eine klage
an die 100 frage tut der was weh medizin
jeweils noch was pharmaindustrie
sozialisiert instrumentalisiert damit
die medizinkosten der tat stecken auch
dort gab es schon mal eine situation in
der du mit deinen youtube einnahmen
angegeben hast
nochmal gut gelungen hat herr pröll war
sicher das beste von allen guten
geistern verlassen so tun als mich die
treue hält
das ist mit wissenschaftliche tests war
zuschauer nach dem winter ist also ich
drauf jetzt in erfurt von einem doktor
selbst der name 3a hatte wie es kein
drama sein soll aber derzeit auf jeden
fall
hast du schon mal als behindert oder
krankenhaus angegeben nur um irgendeinen
vorteil beim leben zu haben
also als behindert oder nein als
karabiner dabei ist ja alles jahr
er gab bloss das war jetzt eine led
werden new york bekommen aber ja warum
man ich weiß kann ich nicht mehr genau
wissen dann was das heißt jetzt für die
sicherheit ausgegeben haben behinderung
würde auch sagen sie mal zu tun das hat
man sich wein brauchen wir dürfen ja so
ist das habe ich sehr schön andere
geschichte auffahrt sich der gleiche die
kamera schauen aber frei gemacht du hast
auch drei gemacht weil er bleibt aber
irgendwie versuch unternehmen das konter
zu drehen auf einzelpersonen könnten
nach keinen fall werde ich gar nicht
geht das okay weil ich immer kurz danach
erwarten dennoch aufnimmt pizza hast du
schon mal einem anderen youtuber
vorgetäuscht ihn zu mögen obwohl du ihn
innerlich hast diesen sport
obwohl überhaupt marx ja okay du bist
also ich habe noch nicht festgestanden
was an der sache ist gestellt wie willst
du dieses ding
okay wir auf stufe 3
ich bin daran hast du jemals an einem
öffentlichen ort der schule der uni oder
sonstwo was nicht an zu hause oder auch
tigers masturbiert das heißt mobil
runterladen
die ja schon wieder wissentlich gelogen
die haben alles falsch
das ist eigentlich nein der bürger soll
ich machen
manche bilder zu sagen wo wir denn in
die stufe 4 jetzt nicht so
das wird was willst du da so was hier
minuten sogar schon ja aber 44 damals
oder alles klar fest leute guckt man
hier bestellen jetzt schön auf stufe
vier deine letzte frage auf der höchsten
stufe ist hast du schon mal etwas
verbotenes gemacht was nach dem gesetz
verboten ist bevor wir jetzt bestraft
werden müssen aber du keine staaten
bekommen fast sicher dass du jetzt
wieder cool werden würde habe ich das du
die lüge
wir müssen sie sich leider geduldiger
verstehen jetzt eine stelle ich mich der
baum
darum geht es im bildschirm eine
handcreme 12 ein bisschen peinlich dass
ich das ist mein lieblingstanz ja also
bleiben wir wissen was natürlich dabei
ist schnell war alles da hast du schon
mal was machst du das es ist vor allem
titel aus das team aus niebüll dass es
hier liegen wir bis jetzt an erklärte
kraus jetzt hier hast du jemals in
deinem leben bei einem kater gehabt
video eine reaktion verspürt
ist so eine soziale frage ja in diesem
video leute geben die sich unter der
bestrahlung zerlegt selbst mal richtig
uns ein video auf freiwilligem anfangs
auch unter dem strich verdienten
ausgleich 19 kommentare favorisiert
dieses video auftritt damit letzten satz
sagen ja ich habe der stufe 3 einfach
alles gestimmt hat
richtige mass gewollt